j'abandonne
est-ce qu'on peut
donc
ok merci
85 mille dollars on l'a pas eu
il était presque géant chéri deux fois à
70 milles et à 80 milles on ne pouvait
pas proposer plus
aux enchères de christie's le petit
carnet de moleskine a été adjugée en
quelques secondes le temps qu'il a fallu
pour que le rêve de dan collins
s'évapore
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est comme ça
en fait il s'agit d'un document très
important est rare nous voulions ramener
en nouvelle écosse il s'agit du carnet
de bord du navire qui a récupéré les
victimes du titanic
le directeur du musée maritime d'halifax
au canada tracks toutes les reliques du
naufrage le plus célèbre de tous les
temps le titanic a coulé au large de la
nouvelle écosse et c'est d'ici que les
secours sont partis
le musée ne présentera pas le petit
journal de bord des secours mais les
vitrines ont de quoi déplacer les foules
c'est un peu ça le problème de dan
collins il doit parfois inciter les
visiteurs à s'aventurer dans les autres
salles
et dams et messieurs la visite de
l'exposition sur l'île de sable va
bientôt commencer si vous voulez bien me
suivre c'est par ici
une petite exposition vaut à elle seule
la visite du musée avec une carte marine
quelques photos et saverne dan collins
embarque les visiteurs à la découverte
d'un des plus étonnants cimetière de
l'atlantique
il ya beaucoup des pages sur les rives
de l'île car il y avait énormément des
changes entre l'amérique du nord et
l'europe les navires passent le plus
souvent tout près de lille sans compter
les pêcheurs qui venait dans la zone il
y avait donc vraiment beaucoup de trafic
dans une mer particulièrement périlleux
le danger avec l'île de sable ce n'était
pas tant les rochers comme partout
ailleurs
c'était plutôt le sable qui piégeait les
bateaux un vrai tueur de navires
beaucoup ont fini leur carrière ici pris
en tenaille entre les bancs de sable et
les vagues qu'ils écrasent est comme de
vulgaires coquille de noix
[Musique]
mais ce même
à l'état
s
sur le -
c'est nos changements
[Musique]
dan collins ne réussit pas un texte bien
appris la grande histoire de sable il a
réécrit tous les jours au gré des
recherches qu'il mène depuis plus de dix
ans
pas besoin d'aller très loin le musée
entassent dans ses réserves tout un
précieux bric à brac qui aura peut-être
un jour la faveur d'une vitrine
nous voici dans la réserve du musée ils
cherchent et étagères il y à des objets
qui appartenaient à des navires échoués
sur l'île de sable
l'horloge provient d'un bateau qui a
fait naufrage près de lille en 1905
un navire anglais nommé le tas et
horloge a été gardée par un des membres
de l'équipe de secours on peut
distinguer les lettres l hôte et à
consommer tout le monde à bord puis ils
ont gardé leurs loges comme un souvenir
êtes vous déjà allé à sable da non
jamais comme la plupart des gens d'une
nouvelle écosse je n'y suis allé que
dans mon imagination
j'aimerais beaucoup me rendre
à vrai dire pour les canadiens et les
gens de nouvelle écosse chute il
n'existe qu'à travers les contes les
histoires les légendes
c'est une île que très peu de personnes
ont vu les élever dans notre imagination
pour découvrir sable il faut un permis
spécial délivré par le ministère
canadien de l'environnement
il faut aussi de bonnes raisons pour y
aller principalement scientifique
des moyens pour affréter un avion et une
bonne dose de chance avec la météo
sable est à 300 km au large d'halifax
lachance dan collins vient de la saisir
l'avion qui ravitaille l'île de sable
fait un aller retour dans la journée
l'occasion est trop belle de sortir de
la réserve de refermer les livres et de
prendre l'air
au bout d'une demi heure de vol le ciel
se transforme noyé dans un épais
brouillard lille se cache quelque part
en dessous un rideau opaque la recouvre
plus de 200 jours par an
parfois l'avion doit rebrousser chemin
[Musique]
ce
cette fois ci ses habitants
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
lille et droit devant elle étire ses 44
kilomètres de sable vers l'est comme un
croissant de lune posé sur l'océan
[Musique]
oh
à
on dirait un désir l'océan
voilà les premiers pas sur l'île de
sable
à
écouter on entend le rugissement des
vagues on ne peut pas les voir mais on
les entend
dan c'est qu'il faut repartir très vite
la météo annonce des orages dans 20
minutes le ciel se refermera sur sable
une bonne surprise à quelques pas de
l'avion la dernière tempête a rejeté un
morceau d'épave
dan a juste le temps de prendre trois ou
quatre clichés pour étudier l'origine de
ce probable naufrage avant de rejoindre
halifax au plus vite
depuis plus de 20 ans jerry diriger les
rares avions qui se posent sur la plage
une ou deux fois par mois
sa petite distraction s'éloigne le
ronflement du bimoteur se perdent et
vient dans la rumeur de l'océan
jerry est beaucoup plus que le chef
d'escale ou leurs représentants sur
l'île de l'état canadien
son silence de bienvenue en dit long
muni de toutes les autorisations les
rares visiteurs ont encore besoin d'un
sésame la confiance de gérer le dernier
verrou qui ouvre sur sable
[Musique]
un léger vertige accompagné premiers pas
sur l'île peut-être cette théorie qui
affirme que le banc de sable dérive
lentement sur l'océan
et pour entrer il vaut mieux oublier
tout ça et suivre gérer
il se transforme constamment
une personne qui est ici pendant les
tempêtes observe qu'il ya de l'érosion
et en tire des conclusions rapides
plus on reste sur l'île puis on
s'aperçoit que d'autres phénomènes qui
existent avec l'érosion
de nouvelles dunes secret par exemple
seule chose que l'on sait avec certitude
c'est que lille change
après quelques années on voit des
endroits et rodez qui se reconstruit une
nouvelle fois c'est juste un cycle
naturel mais on ne peut pas s'opposer à
ça
il faut juste aider la nature a continué
ce qu'elle fait la nature a décidé que
cela doit disparaître on laisse
disparaître on ne peut pas la combattre
pour hisser d'une loin sans végétation
c'est une dune qui se déplace d'une est
mauvais
cet immense dune vient enterrer un
cimetière le sable a recouvert les
tombes les efface tous les jours toutes
les traces des premiers occupants de
lille
on sait plus vraiment où ici ou
peut-être à 50 mètres de là plusieurs
maisons une église même se dresser face
à l'océan
en 1801 des naufrages étaient si
nombreux sur l'île que les autorités de
la nouvelle écosse avait établi une
station de sauvetage
plusieurs familles s'installèrent la
population de l'île a rapidement compté
quelques dizaines de personnes
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
la petite communauté étaient coupés du
monde dans les années 50 des
ravitaillements étaient parachutés
aujourd'hui l'avion suspens isolement de
lille une à deux fois par mois
jerry manuel drôle d'existence dont il
avait tracé la trajectoire très tôt une
vie qui le mène aujourd'hui à surveiller
les passeurs de clandestins les
trafiquants de drogue ou assister les
naufragés mais à part ce voilier ou ce
qu'il en reste lille n'en a plus connu
depuis longtemps
pour les gens qui voulaient travailler
dans l'article
j'étais intéressé
moment envoyé en formation mais a prévu
- d'entraînement toutes les stations de
l'article fermé mais on nous a proposé
d'autres affectations je me suis
retrouvé ici
et duré que trois mois ça fait 20 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la base a été reconstruite
dans la partie ouest de l'île le sable
la recouvrir a certainement un jour en
attendant gérer dirige la station de
recherche scientifique et accueille les
chercheurs les autres maisons de l'île
ont été abandonnées offerte à la
voracité des dunes
dans les années 50 les radars ont fait
leur apparition et nouveaux instruments
améliorer la navigation et le nombre
d'accidents a commencé à diminuer la
station des sauveteurs a donc
officiellement fermé au début des années
1960 1961
le dernier grand naufrage a eu lieu en
il devenait donc de plus en plus
difficile de justifier la présence de
sauveteurs est donc aujourd'hui l'île
est devenue une station météorologique
c'est son activité principale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
le cimetière de l'atlantique est un
jardin fleuri où la brume se lève sur
des créatures qui n'ont rien de
terrifiantes
l'île de sable abrite la plus incroyable
colonie de chevaux sauvages de la
planète
certainement l'une des toutes dernières
introduit sur l'île à la fin du xviiie
siècle les chevaux sont rapidement
retournés à l'état sauvage résistants de
façon exceptionnelle vonage hivernale et
aux tempêtes dévastatrices
300 chevaux et seulement deux personnes
vivent à l'année sur sable jerry et zoé
avec jerry le visiteur pénètre dans
l'île
rencontrant zoé il aura le sentiment
très fort de cueillir ici quelque chose
d'essentiel
l'une des premières choses que je
regarde à la naissance du poulain c'est
son sexe et les marques blanches qu'il
peut avoir et qui vont m'aider à savoir
qu il n
celui ci a une tache blanche sur sa
patte arrière gauche ce qui me sera très
utile dans le futur pour le reconnaître
z'auraient vie sur sable depuis plus de
30 ans
sa vie est un film un roman que certains
ont cherché à écrire zoé ne se résume
pas mais elle accepte d'être accompagné
ce matin à quelques pas de distance
le troupeau qu'elle observe vient
d'accueillir plusieurs poulains en trois
jours
[Musique]
non
tous les jours je sors et j'apprends de
nouvelles choses parfois presque rien
parfois quelque chose de vraiment
intéressant j'apprends tous les jours
par exemple aujourd'hui je n'ai quelle
sorte de végétation ses chevaux
choisissent de manger
c'est dûment de groot pas d'herbe de la
plage et des sortes de poids à légumes
comme l'alpha et qui contient énormément
de protéines
et le poulain juste après sa naissance
et comme elle et commence à grignoter
d'or mais il commence très tôt
on ne sont même pas ce vrai qu'il me
redit déjà quelques plantes
e
[Musique]
en l'absence de prédateurs un sentiment
de paix flotte dans l'air
[Musique]
en
et je vous partage l'île avec
d'innombrables habitants
[Musique]
et
trois cent mille phoques gris ont élu
domicile à sable
[Musique]
la chasse aux phoques a été interdite
sur l'île il y a plus de 30 ans les
voisins de zoé sont donc de plus en plus
nombreux
mais ses amis sa famille sont loin sur
le continent chacun sur une rive voit
l'autre vivre dans la brume
demande si ceci ou cela ne me manque pas
et moi je leur demande si ça ne leur
manquent pas d'être dans un endroit
comme île de sable
et soeurs
c'est une chance unique d'être alors et
c'est dommage que la plupart des gens ne
soient pas aussi heureux que moise qui
travaille dans un tel endroit
la folle de lille est extrêmement
conditionnée par la mer
ces phoques vous en large pour se
nourrir du poisson puis reviennent sur
la plage
lorsqu'il met bas il laisse des
matériaux les empreintes
il est fait que sur la plage invités
fois une humeur et tous ces matériaux
organiques sont recyclés dans la
végétation
cette même végétation que les chevaux
vont bouger pour subsister c'est donc
oui bien sûr les chevaux sont aussi
dépendants de cet environnement marin
ils sont même nourri par l'océan
lorsque je me promène sur les plages de
l'île dans le cadre de mes observations
je vois des phoques tués par des requins
des baleines et des dauphins échoués
des phoques pris au piège des filets de
pêche des poubelles ou des dépôts en
provenance des bateaux du continent
tout est connecté toute la vie sur l'île
est dictée par l'océan
à la station sur un chemin zoé fait le
point avec jerry sur toutes les
découvertes de la semaine
ses plus belles récoltes sont expédiés à
halifax
pour muséum d'histoire naturelle
le colis est toujours adressé aux mêmes
destinataires depuis plus de 20 ans
andrew apte à solo gist en chef
nous recevons régulièrement des
spécimens de la part de jo et
joe et étudie une façon continue et elle
nous envoie des insectes des ossements
de maurs et de malaise de fork
voire même de chevaux
en fait elles utilisent tout ce qui lui
tombe sous la main pour faire ces
paquets emballés les précieux envois
il peut s'agir de matériaux recyclés de
la station de matériaux retrouver sur
les plaintes
il sent qu'il s'agisse de vitry de woods
regardons à l'intérieur
il s'agit de spécimens très fragile
est ce qu'on aura
la joie maintenant pourquoi ce pôle it
est si lourd
il s'agit d'un spécimen irremplaçable
c'est un animal qui vivaient sur lili à
400 ou 500
s'agit d'un mâle très très vieux
grâce à des dons est
regardé comme elles sont usées
il s'agit d'une très belle pièce ajoutée
à notre collection
dans les allées du muséum l'inventaire
est phénoménal une véritable arche de
zoé depuis 30 ans sorry collecte analyse
inventorie et transmet andrew un nombre
incalculable d'ossements de tissus
corporels qui permettront de dessiner le
patrimoine génétique des différentes
espèces qui ont un jour vécu sur l'île
de sable
et si longue est
c'est la plus longue étude biologique ou
menée sur les chevaux sauvages dans le
monde entier
ne travaille pas pour elle-même elle
recueille aussi des choses pour que les
gens puissent étudier dans 150 500
exemple elle pense au futur c'est une
visionnaire
à deux blocs de là dan collins remonte
patiemment la piste de la pièce de bois
abandonné sur la plage
depuis son retour il est plongé dans ces
recherches comme pourrait tirer à
l'infini les quelques minutes qu'il a
passées sur l'île de sable
ce
la première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit c'est que c'était tellement
plus grand que ce que j'avais imaginé
moi qui pensais que c'était qu'une île
de 44 km mais c'est une île très longue
tandis qu'on l'a survolions elle n'en
finissait pas
depuis l'avion j'ai essayer d'apercevoir
des traces de l'ancienne station des
sauveteurs ou des traces des épaves mais
partout ni avec du sable le sable en
boutique ou sur l'île c'était tellement
excitant d'avoir la chance de survoler
puis de poser le pied sur cette île j'ai
tellement lu de livre sur elle j'en ai
même rêver c'était une expérience
extraordinaire d'être enfin là bas
en fouillant dans la réserve dan collins
a exhumé la première carte de sable
dessinée en 1766 est il fait pour ses
collègues une nouvelle visite de sable
parfait parfait
c'est magnifique
aujourd'hui la station principale est
ici la petite maison 2 aux ide et notre
avion intérêt juste ici
et la nouvelle écosse l'île qui si
j'ai les fons du niveau
oui nous sommes juste au bord du plateau
continental près des profondeurs de
l'océan
des glacis gulfstream tous de ce côté le
labrador lui poussent par là
voilà le vrai secret de l'île
sable existe grâce aux tempêtes
lille devrait disparaître glissant
lentement dans les fonds mais ce sont
les tempêtes qui rôde et pose
immanquablement le sable sur l'île
ces mêmes vents et courants violents qui
menace les navigateurs maintiennent
sable en vie
lille se recrée tous les jeux
[Musique]
oh
en déposant du sable les vents et les
courants protecteur rapporte également
les débris toujours plus nombreux de la
société moderne
zoé a un oeil exercé pour discerner dans
ces ordures ce qui enrichira sa
collection particulière
ce sont des ballons gonflables
il arrive sur les plages généralement
entortillé avec des hommes
il échoue ici la plupart des ballons
sont déchiquetés
infatigable et bénévoles sauver parcourt
l'île de long en large
elle rassemble toute sa collection à la
station
avant d'aller l'exposé une ou deux fois
par an sur le continent
ce sont quelques-uns des ballons que
j'ai ramassé
je vais vous montrer un exemple de ce
qui arrive sur la plage
beaucoup d'entre eux viennent du
nord-est des etats-unis
quand on arrive à les identifier on
s'aperçoit que 80 à 90% de ces ballons
proviennent des états unis
cette boîte par exemple contient deux
ballons il ya dix ans nous en récupérons
3000 par an aujourd'hui on en trouve
environ 7000
c'est comme si les parents célébrer les
anniversaires de leurs enfants aux
polluants chaque année un peu plus le
monde qui le relègue est une drôle
d'idée n'est ce pas
si j'ai choisi de m'intéresser au ballon
que je fais souvent des exposés pour les
enfants
bien sûr pour les enfants c'est
difficile de prendre des décisions à
niveau environnementale
ils n'ont pas de véritable pouvoir de
décision
mais peut-être que ce genre de message
il rendra capables de prendre leurs
responsabilités et de faire la
différence tout est
à la croisée des vents et des courants
sable n'est plus une station de
sauvetage mieux elle est devenue un
centre d' alerte sur les pollutions qui
menace l'homme
nous devrions relevé une centaine de
particules par centimètre cube dans
l'atmosphère aujourd'hui ça ne se voit
pas mais l'air est pollué nous trouvons
plus de 4000 particules par centimètre
cube nous décelons aussi certains
pesticides qui sont utilisés en asie du
sud est
nous l'avons récemment appris ces
pesticides se diffuse dans l'océan
pacifique
ensuite ils passent par le détroit de
béring pour se retrouver dans la région
arctique et ils descendent ensuite plus
au sud avec la chaleur ces produits
chimiques s'évapore dans l'est ça montre
que les produits chimiques traverse le
monde entier et c'est incroyable de le
voir à cette échelle on a été les
premiers surpris
[Musique]
avec jerry et zoé la solitude et
l'isolément prennent un visage inattendu
loin très loin de l'oubli du monde
[Musique]
de sable ils ont fait un phare qui
éclaire bien au delà de l'île